now blend that nice and smooth now
before you take out there make sure you
click the season okay and if it needs
any more salt yeah
put little bit in there and just read
blend it okay you can't do that in the
bowl back on right chase it with a spoon
mr. Jordan a baby fast
listen hey listen Johnny you've lost a
lot of weight yes yes
what's the secret any good tips burning
me mouth food for days I mean a good
diet
no I'm Mason Lords better recently I
burn I've cut so so appreciate you Tim
but at night tick with the horses it
really is now it's official stir fish
thanks it's official you're thinner than
Jamie Oliver look at him he looks
amazing right ladies seriously Jamie or
Johnny hey I'm cool now you wouldn't get
that condescending attitude Jimmy we do
me a favor you know last time you're in
Claridge's yeah okay you ran out the
kitchen bags a regular thing you know
unless it's houses behind nine months
ago Hey
yes okay now is amazing minted P veloute
the perfect way finishing a little spoon
of cream cream at the end at the nessus
minted people who take done